i'm joined now by chris hopson the chief
executive of nhs providers which
represents most hospitals in england
good morning chris um
nhs leaders like yourself uh say that uh
you're worried about how the health
system is going to cope this winter
juggling the pressures of clover 19 flu
and the care
backlog
how serious is this going to be
well we are on under an unprecedented
degree of pressure for this time of year
and what we're experiencing is uh very
very high levels of volume of people
coming into accident emergency
departments we know we've got
the ambulance services under real
pressure but wherever you look trevor
write the way across the nhs be in
community services be in mental health
services be it in hospitals the nhs is
under an unprecedented degree of
pressure for this time of year and of
course that's before the traditional
winter peak we know that the nhs tends
to feel most pressure
in early to mid january so there is a
high degree of concern but look let me
just say one thing really really
importantly which is that obviously this
is what the nhs is here for we're here
to provide the best quality of care to
everybody who needs it and our staff are
working absolutely flat out to ensure
that we deliver in line with the nhs
constitution because that's what we're
here for
but the elastic doesn't stretch
infinitely does it i mean um
sadie javed talked uh earlier this month
about the potential
for waiting lists to climb to 13 million
he says well of course
that would be if they hadn't done
anything but um
how high do you think it could get and
could this be
a moment of permanent damage to the nhs
i think it's very difficult to predict
because we simply don't know how many
people who didn't come forward during
covet 19 during the pandemic will
actually come forward and therefore we
are in a bit of a guessing game about
exactly how many but the bit i can
assure you is that nhs staff and nhs
leaders are working incredibly hard at
the moment to create that plan uh to
ensure that we can get through that
backlog as quickly as possible and let
me just give you a couple of stats
which is that for example you know
after the january and february peaking
covered this year
we actually hit a very very high peak of
the number of people waiting for more
than a year so we hit 430 000 people but
hey look by
october we've actually cut that peak by
a third because we're going flat out so
what we're seeing is that staff are
going as fast as they possibly can to
ensure we get through elective activity
as quickly as possible but we are
working under some real really important
constraints here i mean for example you
know if you talk to an average district
general hospital chief exec you know
they'll probably have on average 500
beds what they're saying to us at the
moment is 75 of those beds are out of
action because they're effectively uh
we've had to take them out for covered
infection control 50 of them are
currently filled by covert patients and
50 of them they've got medically fit
patients to discharge but we can't
discharge them partly because of the
pressure on social care has taken
another big
leap and it's got significantly greater
over the last few months so you've got
175 of your 500 beds are out of action
at a point 35 percent of your bed base
is out of action
in terms of the non-covered care and we
know that in winter we're using 98 99
100 capacity of those beds so it's not
entirely surprising that at this point
because of covid because of the pressure
on social care because of the workforce
pressures that we actually don't have
the capacity in the nhs that we need and
that is one of the real things that
everybody needs to realize we've gone
through a decade of the longest and
deepest financial squeeze in nhs history
so we've not been able to grow our
capacity to meet that growing demand
we're putting huge pressure on our
workforce and social care is continuing
to come under greater greater pressure
and those four pressures have been
literally have been growing for a decade
and effectively you can't just turn
around and you know solve all of them by
turning on a sixpence it's going to take
time for the nhs to get back to
an even keel and to recover from covid
we do know from experience though how
that uh
when we hit capacity
where the system gives and that is in
the fact that people have to wait and
particularly uh distressing i think is
uh that they have to wait in emergencies
the royal college of emergency medicine
says that more than 4 500 people died
following 12-hour waits in a department
in england last year
now and their reports of people dying in
ambulances while waiting
outside hospitals i mean are we going to
see more of that this winter
well we know that what happens
trevor is that when pressure increases
the nhs doesn't break it doesn't fall
over
it doesn't reach a tipping point what
happens exactly as you say is that
pressure comes on weights people have to
wait longer we know that patient safety
becomes more at risk and we also know
that the quality of care comes under
pressure but again i just really want to
repeat this this is what nhs staff
are used to dealing with i mean to be
frank they're probably too used to
dealing with it um in terms of the
degree of pressure that we're under we
will do everything we can to ensure we
provide the best quality of care but yes
you're right
the patient safety risk will increase
trevor the the other thing that i think
it's important to really talk about is
the workforce we've got 93 000 staff
vacancies we're spending 6 billion
pounds in terms of to cover those
vacancies and we're now asking the nhs
to do the impossible and as nick
nick simons thomas was saying earlier
this week the government will be
debating the health and care bill we've
got to have a proper approach to
long-term workforce planning and jeremy
hunt with a group of cross-party mps
greens uh snp liberal democrats labor
and um a large number of conservative
mps are basically saying to the
government in their amendment to the
health and care bill this week we have
to have a proper approach to long-term
workforce planning and that will help us
avoid this endless repetition of
problems in winter
thank you because i wanted to come to
this issue of staff um
everything you said is completely
understandable but of course you can't
magic uh trained skilled qualified staff
out of nowhere um and worse still you
can make it uh less attractive for
people to serve in the health service
you recently said that you thought that
the introduction of mandatory
vaccinations for nhs staff could make
the staffing situation even worse um
why and actually do you think the
government simply just ought to drop
that plan
i i think trevor we know that life gets
particularly difficult when you have two
competing objectives and when you've got
two sets of people who've got in a sense
competing rights and it's quite right i
mean i've been very struck by the you
know post bag i've had from patients who
are saying i think it's my right to
ensure that i'm treated by a member of
staff who's been double vaccinated and i
know whether they've been double
vaccinated or not equally i've had quite
a few really strong um emails and
letters from members of staff who feel
very strongly it's their human right to
decide whether they get vaccinated or
not and they get to decide what they
should put in their bodies and the
problem that you've got here is you've
got those two conflicting rights what
we've said is we understand the logic as
to why the government
is going for mandatory vaccination but
what we've said really clearly is that
they need to work with us over the next
few months before that april deadline
arrives so that we can ensure that as
many staff as possible voluntarily going
to take up um the vaccination and we
know that the best way of doing that is
by having patient encouraging supportive
conversations where we really understand
why people have these misplaced and they
are misplaced fears about why they
shouldn't be vaccinated work through
with those those concerns and then
persuade them to be vaccinated and again
you know what's particularly interesting
is we know that there are particular
demographic groups that have got high
levels of vaccine hesitancy we know for
example that
people are colleagues from black
communities we also know that
women who are thinking of getting
pregnant relatively soon they're they're
people who've got higher rates of
vaccine hesitancy and what what our
chief execs tell us is if you can have a
peer-to-peer conversation with people
from the same group explaining why
some members of that group most members
of that group have had the vaccination
it can be very successful but we just
need to do this in a calm patient and
encouraging and supportive way because
if we don't we really do face a major
issue in terms of losing very
significant members of staff just at the
point where we can't afford to do so
well some of those people who
are as you put it vaccine hesitant
um i mean they're they're medics they
are health uh practitioners uh it's not
like they're ignorant about this and
some just won't be persuaded uh where in
the end are you going to come down on
this are you going to say that
ultimately at some point
if people won't have the jab
they simply can't work in your hospitals
well that's where we've got to that's
what the government has been very clear
about we're waiting for the detailed
guidance but all of us in the nhs expect
that if if staff haven't been vaccinated
by that first of april deadline they
will no longer be able to provide
frontline care i mean there is obviously
the opportunity to explore with people
about whether we can redeploy them to
non-front-line care areas but that's
what the government
has decided um needs to be done
but as i said trevor the key the key is
for us to work with our staff to try and
maximize um you know the number of
people
who do take up the vaccine voluntarily